any hope of winning the tournament he is
ready but Magnus will have the white
pieces do you expect him to go for the
kill in this game David judging from the
way he played this first game today it
feels like Magnus is Out For Blood he
starts with the English opening and yeah
we saw yesterday in the final game in
game three when magnusoni needed a draw
he played very passively played for the
draw he was significantly worse after
the opening so I think Magnus is trying
to make amends for that he's now he's
definitely not chosen a passive opening
it's the king's Indian defense the
Magnus occupying the center with all his
Pawns and uh what will you choose now
it's difficult to just kill the game
against the king's Indian
it's difficult to go straight for a draw
it's likely going to be very tense I
like this opening Choice from Eric icy
as well yeah I like this Choice as well
you know it is combative it is dynamic
it is everything he needs and uh well
it's uh putting a question mark on a
Magnus because what is he gonna play is
he going to try to play a solid
variation is he perhaps going to just
accelerate the battle and play something
very aggressive we will see you know
bear in mind the drawer is quite a good
result then he would be half a point
away from securing the tournament
victory yeah I mean I think he had this
against the Romanian didn't he in the
last competition where he played the
main line which is uh bringing the other
night out and that was a very very
exciting game where he actually sacked a
queen in the end to get Victory and he's
gone for an older by say old variation
the same-ish variation
um which is a very decent line as well
but that little poor move that Magnus
played I remember it was uh gooffield a
Russian Grandmaster who loved playing
this position as black you said what a
move you can't play this move where's
the White Knight gonna go he really
wasn't a fan of this but it is of course
a good a good line and uh it should be
fun this game because all the pieces are
gonna remain on the board and uh Black's
now got to decide what what porn he's
gonna push and there's normally a choice
of two here isn't there really David uh
that he can try to go for
yeah normally black pushes upon either
the black e-pawn or C Pawn to challenge
White Center you can't allow white to
just maintain the Central Pawn structure
forever and then slowly develop pieces
behind you you need to fight for squares
fight for space and Ivanka have there
been many games in this many many games
and I can tell you that this particular
variation seems to be a firm favorite of
the computers
so we've got uh Leela chasero playing
this another one called rough chain
rough card I don't know how to pronounce
it stockfish 14. stockfish 15 has tried
it Komodo try Dragon so we've got a lot
of high level games remember I love
their ratings these these computers have
ratings of like
3309 oh my
wow 3809 yeah oh wow above perfect but
not too bad yeah
decent rating yeah uh meanwhile we do
see one of your Pawn pushers Simon and
Magnus immediately blocks up the center
white can't let things open up because
White's lacking in development uh
White's King still several moves away
from castling and uh it's a nice Pawn
chain for white but black I'm expecting
to chip away at that pawn structure
again just first kicking backwards
Bishop
White's Bishop is happy to actually lose
time and uh now Arjun trying to open the
center
or main Life Theory this I mean I
remember playing this line as white
um some of course a long time ago at
least 20 years ago uh it was one of my
favorite variations but black does does
get a lot of counter play so this is
this is a good choice for margin who
really needs to win has to win one of
the games of black to have any chance so
he's picked the right opening and and
there's many moves that black can try
here to to gain counter play but first
of all he develops his Knight which is
coming towards the center and again this
is all pretty pretty uh known Theory so
far
um and the White Knight now come back
around so both sides developing pretty
naughty my understanding though was that
this night move that Arjun has made or
slightly inaccurate and the reason is
because of magnus's move because that
Knight really wants to be the White
Knight sorry wordy wants to be on the F2
Square it's a good point yeah well well
spotted and we saw that Magnus in his
last game eliminated that night with his
Bishop but Arjun do that because he's
blocked it so it's a good point and now
the White Knight gets his ideal Square
first of all you have to stop Black's
plan always look what your opponent's
last move is always try to work out what
they're trying to do and of course he
doesn't stop it because I've said that
and actually Matthew Sadler used to play
this way with the white pieces famous
English Grandmaster who's well known for
his uh computer expertise and I do
believe this chessboard course is on
sale at the moment you should check it
out it's a brilliant course but
um yeah this is interesting though David
allowing black to now push on the queen
side can I just oh yeah David's got it
highlighted sorry go on your right no no
I was um you I'll leave it to you yeah
um so just to backtrack a couple of
moves in this position white after the
black porn push white could not actually
take this pawn it looks like a free uh
Pawn here it's defended by the queen but
black now has a nasty tactic Black's
Knight can jump out the way capture a
pawn hitting the White Queen and when
this Knight is captured the black queen
can sweeping uh with a check also
hitting the white Bishop so example here
black takes the white bishop and black
has full domination over the dark
squares and Magnus instead of taking
this Pawn jumped back with his Knight so
now the queen coming up would never be a
check along this diagonal so this spawn
was finally threatened so black didn't
have time to commit sure and uh push his
Pawn so we saw uh let's catch up with
the gaming position it's all about this
Pawn break Magnus is castled in the
meantime and uh Black's trying to force
this one through as you mentioned
earlier Simon if he gets this one push
because she gets quite a lot of play
yeah I missed he couldn't do that um
earlier situation but also if you
compare the development of both sides
you can see that white has cleared his
first rank so all the white Knights and
Bishops are sitting nicely on the other
hand black black hasn't managed to do
that because he's got this light squared
Bishop which is a real pain in this
variation for black because it can't
can't often find a good square but he is
he has got a mini positional fret now
which Magnus needs to
um think about how to deal with does he
allow black to play this move or does he
try to hold it up somehow yeah
um would you uh would you try to stop
that one or prepare to meet it with uh
some counter-attack yeah that's a good
question Simon uh usually there's two
strategies right one you either just
push a pawn for it and you say okay if
you march forward I'll capture you on
passant but
um here it's
always unclear right whether capturing
on person actually helps for example
blacks can recapture and this point is
just as weak as any of Black's pawns
um it's not clear who this really helps
long term for example the Black Knight
can always jump forward later on and
start trying to jump into the center I'm
not sure I would go for this I'm always
hesitant unless I can guarantee that
black gets no counter play I have to
push this one I think I'd be very
tempted to swap dark Square Bishops off
here I mean uh with white I mean to try
and start targeting Black's King me too
and I just wanted to point out that
there's one game in my database between
uh two players at the Danish open and
their white show is a different plan
which is actually to slide The Rook one
square across and the whole idea is to
meet the pawn push with a counter push
yeah this is this is the Sandler plan
that I I was mentioning earlier I don't
remember Matthew Sadler used to do this
time and time again and actually he got
the initiative from the queen side uh
from doing this plan but I also like
what Magnus has done makes a lot of
sense to annoy Black's position with
this bishop move yep the queen attacks
and one thing you definitely don't want
to do is block with a pawn because now
even if the bishop steps back where it
came from suddenly Black's piece is
completely blocked in and you've also
weakened some squares in the middle of
your Camp
um knowing my luck he'll probably play
this move now after I said it's the one
thing you definitely don't want to do
but usually in this position with your
queen hit you either block for example
you could potentially block potentially
block with your dark Squad Bishop but
this accelerates White's plan of trading
these Bishops anyway I think that's what
Magnus wants to achieve
um the other other move here the
alternative would be to move the queen
but again the queen looks a bit clumsily
placed not too many squares for her what
would you do here uh Simon Ivanka with
the queen hit if you're enlarging the
shoes
a tricky one I mean I I might I might
decide that I have to block with a
bishop here because I I don't like the
Alternatives
um but as you mentioned White's white
generally wants to exchange off the dark
Square Bishops for a couple of reasons
number one black star Square Bishop that
one highlighted is cutting all the way
across the board so it's generally got
great range and also it's the only
Defender really of Black's King so later
on if you can get rid of that Bishop
from the white perspective Black's King
becomes a little little bit more of a
juicier Target to attack
um slowly well generally with this Pawn
push that David has shown this is the
main main way to to get through the
center and towards the black king so
it's already a very tricky decision for
black to make how do you deal with it
and he has done a very understandable
move there as well yeah just got his
Queen out the way and okay Magnus after
misplacing The Black Queen now he
insists on a bishop exchange this bishop
exchange is pretty much guaranteed
because sir if the black Bishop runs
away from this exchange then The Rook
falls behind it
so yeah Magnus is getting that strategic
goal that he's been craving for a while
now getting Black's best piece best
minor piece at least off the board
consistent strategy yeah it's consistent
and it's a tense position uh well
anything can happen right now and uh
whilst Arjun is thinking I want to share
with you a few pictures the first one
comes courtesy of sod alamat who says
guess whose t-shirt is this one
wait for it it's a good one
here it is
five minutes I approve I want that one
actually very black what is not my color
and uh Ariane illigan also stands with
us shares with us a picture and uh says
lord of the boards wait for it it's a
good one too right off the board lord of
the boards and here we are
you are Galadriel uh Kaya oh I can't
remember the the name of the brown
haired elf who the hell am I
who's that person that's the dwarf all
right yeah
then we have David uh yeah
couldn't you have been Gandalf Simon oh
maybe yeah
yeah that doesn't look like him I always
thought Frodo was quite annoying
actually oh thanks Simon
holy yeah you don't deserve to be oh
here we go I'm gonna try and dig a hole
now that's why David should not be Frodo
because David is a pleasure to be here
next to you who would you say who you
who would you like to beat David in Lord
of the Rings yeah if you could pick one
character
and I think you're more of an arrogant
character I'd love to be
Frodo has the most important role the
ring bearer
maybe but my feet aren't as hair as his
I should mention
has he got everything Hobbits too though
right yeah okay this has been there
thank you very much for sending us your
pictures and if you two want to send us
your tweets your pictures your selfies
your thoughts who your shirt who you're
cheering for then please tweet us using
the hashtag chess Champs and we will
feature them on the show you might have
to speed up doing that because if Magnus
wins this game the tournament is over
the bar is definitely over to his side
and he has definitely more time on the
clock than Arjun as well
yeah
he's really asking for trouble with his
last couple of moves he traded off the
dark Squad Bishops I'm surprised he did
it on White's terms look at that White
Queen yeah yeah so close to the black
king it feels like trouble I mean you
could move the Knight back around yeah I
mean try to you know white could just go
for checkmate here there's one idea
um but there's there's many tempting
things going on here yeah uh this is a
monster threat bringing the knight in
and then sliding the White Queen up
trapping the king Checkmate yeah this is
dangerous I guess look at the valuation
part as well yeah wow actually uh White
traded phones first so another option is
to even slide this rook in first trying
to go this angle uh but yeah the
evaluation part this means that white is
winning Magnus has a winning idea what
is it okay I was thinking push the pawn
yeah you think you're right the computer
stockfish confirms as we see in front of
us top three moves this is number one
pushing a pawn and the idea ibanker go
forward or even even you might want to
go Alice Simon and play Bishop takes
Pawn just that explode open but my first
reaction that pawn goes all the way it's
a wrecking ball I mean by both pawns are
very tempted to push aren't they there
you can even push the one right in the
center and bring a knight in behind it
this is a very common idea will he find
this move I mean it's not I think he
will yeah he's pretty good isn't he yeah
and I think the reason this is so strong
is because the move we quite like Simon
which is the second best uh computer
option also very natural I think this
might allow the black queen to come into
the center and when we threaten
Checkmate the black queen can swoop back
and defend Queen exchange probably why
still doing quite well but uh no
Checkmate this move
just stops the queen coming over to the
defense of her King okay he doesn't go
for it Magnus he plays one of the
computer's top choices we see that that
was the third choice by stockfish using
the white Rook also looks very good to
be honest also maybe the most or one of
the most natural moves in the position
clear threat the Knight is undefended
but this might be winning a pawn
mightn't it it might win a Pawn on the
queen side but sometimes that gets black
counter play
um you know it it's very hard now for
black to hang on to the the pawn he
pushed forwards yeah so for example okay
he does push forward wow for example if
the Rook had blocked we would have seen
an exchange and as Simon mentioned this
Pawn just drops Whitewood take it
defended by the bishop uh instead he's
going Pawn down in a different way
pushing this guy
maybe this is just the best of a bad
Bunch like the least uh the Lesser evil
uh the Knight will drop whitesnite will
also drop but white Windsor Pawn at the
end white wins the black porn porn up
and with a potential attack
still looks good not winning on the
spots the tournament isn't over yet but
uh yeah Arjun on the ropes
wow
another game Magnus just playing
fantastic chess
just been a I mean this one's been a
difficult opening for Arjun but he
needed to take risks he knows he's
almost in a must-win situation
so we can't for arjun's opening Choice
uh but Magnus he's just so well prepared
and
I saw a quote by I think it was Peter
lecko and he was saying yeah it's just
Magnus he has a game plan we mentioned
many times he plays every opening Under
the Sun but he chooses specific openings
that Target each opponent's weaknesses
so if he knows his opponent is in a
must-win situation he'll provoke them or
he'll just shut down the game
um if he knows the like passive
positions he'll go aggressive if he
knows they like attacking he'll just
shut them down frustrate them is he the
expert in using psychology yeah
basically yeah exactly he just Cherry
picks his openings because he knows
pretty much everything and he knows all
these little details these little
nuances
so good at cherry picking his openings
yeah
and well his chest knowledge is
spectacular I have to say and
incidentally I saw on Facebook
I forgotten the name of the Spanish
Grandmaster so you'll have to forgive me
but he was talking about you know that
93 move end game that he played with
Vincent kymer apparently that a very
very similar almost identical position
had happened in a Casper of karpov match
oh 1986. and uh Carl a Casper of gave a
recommendation in his book I like what
was the best plan
and and Magnus basically did that plan
wow
so uh yeah I mean that's one level the
youngsters in this tournament the
teenagers they've impressed so much but
that's one area they just can't compete
yet
um they just don't have I mean they
haven't been playing chess long enough
to accumulate all that knowledge
remember the grand Masters mace
so yeah if I have to give credit where
it's due
yeah it's it's one thing like you know
seeing these games and remembering them
but it's another thing keeping them in
your long-term memory you know because
it's very easy well when you're
preparing for a tournament you can learn
an opening idea you can learn an idea
but recalling that information five
years later I think nearly everyone
struggles except for some of these
amazing elite players they seem to be
able to uh they have fantastic memory
and Magnus is known to have this uh
amazing recall uh about so about the
things he's picked up basically I know
real skill yeah and meanwhile um arjun's
work has gone to the second row I think
this is good news I mean the shade the
pity is that the rest of the pieces are
quite passive but you know you've got to
be optimistic and you were talking about
memory and perhaps life skills
assignment and we have a question from
Kent left Gran who says could chess
skills and knowledge improve your
strategic thinking skills off the board
I.E in real life
I mean do you think yeah I guess they
can I mean they don't necessarily
necessarily correlate
um but you can certainly learn skills in
life that you you learn in chess I mean
you know for example patience planning
is something that you need in chess
um and you can obviously take that fruit
to business or other areas you know if
you're starting a business or you're
planning about just how to improve
yourself really and David I would have
thought there's many sort of other
things that can be relevant as well yeah
just general decision making weighing up
the pros and cons evaluating certain uh
kind of things in life I guess but
you're right Simon there's plenty of
actual chess players who they start
young they play chess but then they
gravitate towards business or towards uh
I mean other fields Finance whatever it
is yeah I mean Finance was a big one
wasn't it in England there was many uh
great players going back probably 20
years who became International masters
Grand Masters they're the best chess
players but then they turn those skills
to mainly finance and Bank
and I think most of them all became
millionaires by by using those skills so
it's definitely helps I think yeah yeah
which was the wrong career path
you know I remember a few a few years
back uh in the UK they had this kind of
big National IQ test that they did on TV
and I remember that I was especially bad
at the logic and the maths
and their recommendation for improving
these skills was play chess I was like
I was like that stung
it's uh yeah I think there's some
transferable skills but that doesn't
necessarily mean that uh you know it's
all positive I struggle in real life
from perfectionism as well and uh
indecision
sometimes it's just like in chess
there's so many options I spend so much
time on the clock I'm the same in life
decisions are hard yeah
you don't overthink too much in life
that's uh yeah well so easy to get
decision fatigue I'm I'm there with you
David and uh
oh it's a question for our guys see how
to improve his pieces and there he
centralizes his Queen yeah very natural
he comes with a threat Black's Queen is
attacking White's the undefended seaporn
computer doesn't like it
oh no I'm not really sure why I don't
see the refutation yet but maybe it's
just the fact that this queen is on a
vulnerable Square once the threat is
dealt with uh for example if white
defends this born White's Queen can even
come back if really necessary the White
Queen could come the whole way back to
the first rank defend everything kick
away the black Rook
maybe okay there we go yeah and maybe
then the the pawn is ready to push so
black has to keep the Frets going and uh
you know white would love to push that
pawn attacking the queen which you saw
earlier but not in this position because
it would it would lose lose big pawns so
maybe you can do it anyway Simon maybe
this is uh the reason the evaluation bar
likes white so much because even an end
game we talked about going for trackmate
but now we can switch
focus and if we kick the queen uh she
moves after an exchange maybe white can
just go Pawn hunting
uh in this type of structure which
resembles what we call a benoni defense
it started as the king's Indian then
this is always the weakness again the
base of the pawn chain and
can't see how to defend it that looks
really strong yeah I mean combined with
this the Central Pawn coming forward so
that's I mean if Black's not actually
threatening to take that pawn
then it's really bad news for Arjun and
Magna slowing down okay he's gone for a
little bit
safer option but that Knight's also on
quite a good route uh and the pawn is
still ready to come forwards but I like
your move David your move look even even
stronger yeah I mean uh Magnus just not
in the mood to take any risks
understandable this pawn move might
happen later and as you say the White
Knight
is normally the dream square and the
structure because it will later hit the
biggest weakness in the black Camp takes
a while but Magnus has that luxury
it's just a pawn up essentially in this
position and full control
Eric I see it just feels like he's
caught Magnus the worst possible moment
it's just on fire
whole tournament
incredible he hasn't lost well he lost
one game to Iranian to Iranian except
from the one against Neiman yep yep
incredible
yeah and uh okay we like this move right
Simon we always like this move sorry my
Iris uh this move sorry uh the black
porn pushing
yeah I'm going to cause some kind of
confusion but problems you don't have
much backup with any other piece except
for your queen and the black queen is
sort of okay sitting on a pretty bad
Square as well so get kicked right yeah
it is but you know black does have one
thing hope
[Laughter]
I hope that kills you Ivanka that's the
yeah yeah I mean you're right you've got
to be positive Magnus does play this
move the most natural with the queen is
forced somewhere does she go this way
where she's not really doing too much
does she step back this way
yeah just feels like yeah yeah I feel
that he has to just make some kind of
vaguely active move with the queen I
think if he sounds The Retreat that's
just going to inspire Magnus to carry on
I mean at least pretend to threaten
something yeah well I mean
it's a nice idea but
you can't even pretend that's the
problem I mean you've got to move the
queen nearly all the way back I mean if
you move it over here it gets hit by the
bishop or something
it has to go back again and all your
other pieces are back at it already so
it's uh be forced into the corner and
then some Omni samples for example
something like this Simon what do you
think of this position for black
all pieces yeah I'm just trying to set
the board back up yeah yeah
I don't know that's I mean that's the
type of thing that's happening in the
current position yeah yeah it's just
disaster unfortunately for aragosi
Magnus has been such class though I mean
you know we shouldn't be too hard on
um Arjun because it's just been the
Magna show hasn't it he's played
fantastic chess not taking any risks but
just playing good moves various
different openings which is nice to see
as well and he's not giving his opponent
chances that's that's a really important
thing you know he doesn't give chances
away
um he's always putting the ball in the
back of the net
where's the queen going okay so the
goodest Square as any I feel this one
um and there's a lot of tempting ideas
here do you improve your pieces here
again
um or do you try to push in the center
very quickly or maybe that Rook move
that you said David has so many moves
isn't there I think he's just improving
his pieces here he is yeah I did like
your David's Rook move he looked quite
tempting they look very tempting
especially because it eyed up the queen
but okay magnus's move is great you know
the Knight is uh threatening to jump
forward to the G4 Square attack the
queen and uh once again that pawn push
is in the Horizon and it's not just that
pawn push it's that uh Target on D6 as
well
yeah even if black wasn't up one down
even if you could kind of give black an
extra Pawn I don't know somewhere on the
a file for example I think white just
had some long-term strategic Advantage
anyway so you give them material
strategic advantage
at some point later that will transform
into a direct attack quite likely
against the black king
I mean you could even be tempted to
sacrifice a pawn I mean as white in
these positions slow things open in the
center this is a very very normal idea
in this structure and one you should
probably be aware of
um when if you're playing this this kind
of Pawn structure which does come out
and the benoni King's Indian defense and
this Pawn with the Knight coming to that
square is is the real sort of key uh
what a beautiful square that Knight
would gain there maybe it's not
necessary I I don't I don't think he'd
play this if there's something safer
because you have to give up a pawn why
do that keep it simple but again it it
could just be killing as well at the
right time you're right it's the one to
look out for if it works then it nearly
always gives a massive advantage in
these types of structures right yeah I
mean here you'd have to do some
calculating this is what Magnus is may
be thinking right now if the pawn is
captured Knight jumping can the black
queen take this Pawn for example yeah I
mean it looks like it's hanging together
by a thread for black okay keep playing
it so he's very confident that tactics
are working in favor so if it works this
could be the end maybe we can run
through that line again then yeah I mean
if you don't take this Pawn you might as
well just resign yeah because you're
going to be born down and being
steamrollered bulldozered in the center
and okay White's not jumping in I mean
you can make an argument for jumping
this way as well yeah definitely because
definitely I mean the black queen does
it have to go back to its starting
Square which you pointed out David we
were joking about this but mate but then
the white Pawn in the center comes
forwards it's it this is just an
absolute that looks really strong
tonight going that way as well yeah I
think maybe this is the easiest way if
you go the other way with the white
knight then because there's uh you've
blocked up the e-file
at least black can take here potentially
I mean to be honest I still see a few
scary ways uh for work to continue but
yeah I mean if you go the other way
Queen takes Pawn is no longer possible
due to a pin and the black Rook would
fall he's gone all the way back he's
gone all the way back immediately do you
know what you should have done David I
think I think you said it just resign
yeah no I mean it's it's that point of
the game now
I mean if your Magnus worse comes to
worse you take a pawn here uh you have
to deal with your Rook
Magnus will want to do something more
flashy uh again worse comes to worse you
Retreat your Rook or maybe even move it
this way if you want to keep it safe but
Magnus might be looking for more direct
options I mean other ideas that come to
mind would be for example taking this
Knight and then throwing a pawn forward
in the center trying to break through to
the black king on this way white can
push this Pawn next to open up the white
Queen's diagonal white tonight is coming
into the center
ugh it just looks I mean your sport for
Choice here
what would you guys be thinking how
would your thought process go I I would
probably look at uh just Pawn takes Porn
first of all because I'm going to be two
pawns up and if that keeps my initiative
going then then why not um just you know
win another pawn and keep attacking you
know that that would be my first fault
but not bad pawns either I mean or so
many squares and they're extra pawns
both of them so that that would be maybe
the simple The Simple Solution and I
think like you know just in case I
miscalculate something simple is good I
guess yeah whether you just decide to
play something later at least if you
work out this one you have it as a
backup plan
and uh yeah I guess also very safe just
move the Rook
um the only problem is burning a lot of
time on the clock when you have four or
five very very nice options but Magnus
has plenty of time so you just have to
worry about that
for now extra three minutes on the clock
an extra two pawns on the board
potentially okay he drops back with his
Rook also understandable
hitting this Pawn now again every guys
he has to capture in the center
otherwise he's just gonna be two pawns
down for free and this is another idea
Simon you mentioned very typical very
thematic in this type of scenario he's
blast open the king side yeah and the
queen is now the White Queen look at
that diagonal which you pointed out
there that it can just fly in maybe of a
night coming in The Rook the bishop oh
everything the queen
oh no this is over for example Pawn
takes porn suddenly Eric I sees a pawn
up but uh it doesn't matter I I mean I'm
wondering how we finish this I guess we
jump in with the White Queen first of
all as you say the White Knight can jump
in the white rookers
[Laughter]
yeah does it crisscross no no bowden's
mate begins to be David knows it right
you've got it right he got it right
Magnus got it wrong
this would be a check Pawn takes and
it's gonna we might see it David we are
seeing this threat on the board at least
this would end in Checkmate uh the
bishop hits the king the queen cuts off
the King on this diagonal
um I don't know it'd be I thought it's
bowden's mate with the two Bishops it is
but Lester are checkmates ah yes that's
right it does ring a bell uh so in this
position this was the massive threat
Rook across check from White and Arjun
has defended
he's uh prevented that with his Knight
coming back the Knight is covering the
square but maybe it's time to bring the
white knight in now I mean there's so
many moves here guys you know I was
joking about putting all blacks pieces
on the background yes it's actually
happened again all of his pieces this is
backs to the wall park the bus this is
park the bus literally and uh
it won't work out well the rhyme does go
Knight and f8 there's no mate but I
think we'll see an exception to that
rule I mean the White Queen might even
step back one square allowing the white
Rook to cut there's so many people
there's so many moves that one
assignment that are just uh floating in
the position bring the Knight yeah I
mean so many tempting moves there and
he's just spending his time really nice
and don't get excited this is what one
thing that is very easy to get carried
away get excited this is also very
strong I think you can get ready to push
Pawn forwards but it's uh ready to push
and then this bishop will come to life
or as a queen check as well
that's even more yeah deadly and uh the
funny thing is not one of Black's pieces
can come to the aid of Black's King
yep the evaluation bar finally realizes
how deadly this attack is and uh yeah as
Ivanka mentions this piece of wrong side
of the board wrong side of the board
Queen cut off can't participate The Rook
stuck the knights are doing a good
defensive job at least but
it's defending alone
yeah that's where the last few moves of
this tournament
x-rated stuff here
you know nice thank you unfortunately it
is Magnus in killer mode you know he's
just Relentless he really is not
stopping here
and if we had any doubt that Magnus
would slip up he has come in today in an
absolute fighting mode he is the Beast I
mean yesterday he was critical of his
play
can he even be that today has there been
any flaws at all
I mean we know he's self-critical and uh
we know he has extremely high standards
for himself but
I don't think we can uh I think we need
to call him out I think he's critical
please jump in if he doesn't okay I
think if any of us played a game like
this we'd be like oh best game of our
career yeah Magnus is like ah but I
could have done better here yeah
Masterpiece now if he doesn't come to
the interview Kyle with a smile as big
as the Cheshire Cat
then we we have to criticize it we have
to go come on Magnus this is incredible
I mean it's been so consistent
throughout the tournament you know the
record-breaking 34 points in the
preliminary is losing just one game to
aronian Breaking 2900 with this win
smashing through that Golden Barrier
and I mean our dream of his last movie
was trying to use the Rook to defend but
you don't even have to pull the trigger
quite yet if you're white here but yeah
he's he's going to be over 2 900 ratings
on the tour with this this win it's just
it was just phenomenal achievement yeah
just got to do it on on you know in real
life now and he's he's there so real
life real life this is real life Simon
yeah I suppose so like over the board
yeah I think it's there that's what I
was looking at yeah imagine being over 2
900 In classical rapid Blitz Fisher
random yeah wow I think that might be
the Pinnacle yeah it doesn't get much
better than that we asked him I think it
was after a preliminaries if there was
no one was it some type I asked him if
we're seeing a generation shift in chess
and he said yeah definitely already
seeing that I'm not so sure
he seems ready to stay up there yeah I
mean he's extra motivated playing all
these young young guys yeah I guess it
must be tiring playing people of his
same generation for Magnus
hundreds of times uh you know their
Styles you know their openings you know
how the games go when you play someone
young it's fresh it's different ideas
it's a different style of Chess
um is he going to try to go for
something a bit of flair I'm thinking
move the Knight into the middle don't do
this at home it's the kind of move where
there's no point to do but is he is he
going to try to find a stylish finish or
something yeah I mean I I wouldn't be
doing that and myself but yeah or is he
gonna just try to find a clinical finish
I mean what is the most clinical finish
here pushing the pawn in the middle is
there a queen check instead have to
calculate the end yep so Queen check
looks very strong pushing this Pawn
makes sense you open up the bishop on
this diagonal uh the black Bishop will
block
hmm what's the follow-up I mean it's
hanging Again by a thread for
um
for black right now
I guess you can give a check yeah then
take the bishop probably yeah and then
if the Knight blocks for example I mean
you take this Knight you can take the
bishop
I mean either way you win Rook takes and
now you can take this Knight this is a
nice way discovered attack against the
black queen
undefended maybe black can defend better
there I'm not sure okay Magnus we're
gonna find out he has opened up his
Bishop
this bishop is a real Archer firing
arrows down at the black king
I just didn't see how to defend like
this is just a very natural move you
take away more squares than black pieces
you open your Bishop you open another
attacking piece
um and you're just asking black what are
you gonna do and don't think as much
that can be done you're attacking with
three right now with the Knight and Rook
on standby wow yeah and one minute left
for Arjun aragaisi do you think that
means also one minute left in the final
basically not much time the clock is
ticking down and uh with it Origins
chances
and we're expecting Bishop takes Bishop
right I think Queen check is going to be
worth picking in as well and maybe the
black king has to move but
you know I'm just trying to find the
actual killer killer so queen queen
check looks
like it's a good move because it lines
up against the black queen showing those
tactics David demonstrated but is there
a killer killer after the King goes in
the corner there should be yeah let's
quickly investigate before Magnus plays
his move he's doing the same as we're
doing he knows it's winning he I mean
just looking at this position you can
tell but uh you need the killer blue so
he's calculating
checks first then he'll look for the
captures the threats this check as we
showed the Knight jumping in the way I
can just take the bishop off and this
Knight will drop next move uh for
example and then we win the queen this
is the line we showed earlier and
therefore Simon thinks and I think
correctly that the only move if you
can't block with the Knight is to move
into the corner it looks so dangerous
but you can meet this check with a night
block
otherwise this would be the lawnmower
lawnmower Checkmate I think that would
be I mean can you just uh first
first of all just go for material
how do you go for material here yeah I
was thought if you could uh flick in a
queen check before going to work so
Queen check I mean take this Pawn or do
you want to look across here maybe take
them we're going to see this we're going
to see it okay he's given a check
and does the queen come over one square
it does yeah lining up against this
Knight only only move to save of the
game is to use the Rook to defend yep
and what's the Tipping Point how do you
push black over the edge
I still don't see it this bishop is
defended by Black's rook in the center
this Knight is defended by the other
Rook
suddenly these two pieces can't really
get in
[Music]
where's the finishing touch
maybe if you want to keep things simple
I guess you just trade off the Bishops
and then maybe you take this Pawn with
the queen next move you start to bring
the Knight into the center or maybe this
way
back to life isn't it doesn't seem like
the the smoothest way to convert the
advantage here I mean I we didn't know
what the win was but is there something
easier than that okay he's going for
this let's go for this okay we see that
position on the board Queen takes Pawn
has happened so white will jump in with
his Knight and still looking good the
black king stuck in the corner but uh
okay Eric I see
credit to him he survived the West yeah
and I mean it's still uphill struggle
can he continue surviving it's level
pawns on the board right now
but strategically still dominant for
white
and okay defensive piece has come along
you love those fiend shadowed for
extinctly Simon definitely I mean it
seems like there's some chances to
survive this to me I mean like he's got
he's got a bit of a defensive formation
the there's no it's materially equal so
there's no no advantage and
time on the clock as well yeah yeah yeah
so it's uh not quite over it's turned
the Indians away and yeah fair play to
Arjun I mean he's so good we know him
for attacking for being great in the
opening for being really smooth uh
technically in the end game but
defensively he's showing that
you know he's up there with the best I
don't think many people would just
survive this long against Magnus from
that position earlier
no I think I mean if you can get the
Queens off here that would be uh you
know back in the game definitely so I'd
love to move my queen up one square if I
was black here right and uh I was was
quite kind of curious because Magnus
position looks so overwhelming that it's
difficult to believe that
the material is equal
I would have thought that he had some
advantage to say it somewhere but I like
his last move you know it's a very
Magnus Type move he's just making a
square available for the white king to
run to and also maybe the White Knight
can springboard to a protected G4 Square
what is the what is the reason Magnus is
so much better in this game actually
everything looks
you know and I look at it it doesn't
look like it to me King safety is the
main thing if you take a look at Black's
King it's defended by pieces and that's
not the optimal use of your pieces I
mean you'd rather have the Rope
attack attacking yeah on the center line
you certainly would not like the Knight
to be acting like a pawn and uh Arjun
playing Simon's move trying to offer a
trade of queens and Magnus is absolutely
not no way it's essentially like a
battle if you imagine all the Warriors
and you've got your best fighters your
best soldiers standing at the back you
know in the tent guarding their King
when actually all your foot soldiers are
just there being beaten up by the
opponent's best fighters and so here
white setup is he has the kind of
bodyguards in front of his King the
White Queen the white Rook White Knight
they're open to do what they want the
best fighters and if you look look at
Black's night it will never ever move
from in front of his King it's just
stuck there so the rest of the board uh
black is playing a night down
essentially
so it's I'm still surprised as well that
the evaluation bar is that much in
Black's favorite in magnus's favor sorry
but uh it's clearly clearly good for
white hair again just comparison of the
Kings I mean this looks like the killer
blowed to me I I think Arjun might have
been relying on moving a pawn to unleash
the queen but it just doesn't work you
just lose material five seconds oh I
have to make a move okay and he does
Simon well I think you can just take the
rook and take the pawn next move Black's
Queen is coming out and Black's Queen is
going to hit on the other well at least
I'm finding ways to lose this position
so this is a counter attack Black's
Queen has suddenly opened up a threat
against White's Rook on the side of the
board
I mean taking that black Rooks looks
like a good step I mean the White Rock
can always go up and take a pawn after
and you've got a queen you're coming to
the back rank there are plenty of ways
but too much Rook can go and take the
Black Knights there's other options yeah
and uh he does take the rook and now
aragaisy has to catch the rook and uh
yeah Rook takes pawn and Black's
position is now starting to fall apart
yeah and uh now we do a quick count
white is also one point up with uh an
ongoing attack a Regice is trying his
best though the White Queen Under threat
but uh only for one move because Magnus
is the one that delivers a check first
and either black is gonna trade off
Rooks or he has to step forward with his
King and uh well rook's set of Rooks are
going to leave the board
yeah and now Magnus is going to start
mopping up he gives a queen track
a second potentially third Pawn is going
to fall
um I I still think I Regice is defended
so well but the problem is you're
playing the best player in the world and
you don't always have to go for
checkmate as Magnus is showing he's just
playing materially now he's going to
give another check most likely with the
White Queen
and the one thing he has to avoid Magnus
is the black queen coming in to start
checking the white king white King's
slightly vulnerable so with this check
Magnus loves to centralize his Queen
first of all but with this check he's
covering any potential Queen jumps uh
night jumps for black
and a big double threat hitting the
black queen and threatening to go with
the White Queen in front of black king
Checkmate and black has no checks him
and he has a knight check but it's it
doesn't help uh it's you can't stop chat
mate or losing your queen here yeah
Checkmate is coming one way or the other
at the evaluation bar is shot all the
way up no defense 10 seconds on the
clock
he throws in one last desperate check
this Knight can just safely be captured
and maybe another check with the black
queen but I can't even block with the
queen here yeah simple way there we go
Magnus swapping the Queen's off extra
night extra Pawn
he's gonna win the tournament wow and
there it is it's over ordinary guys he
resigns facing
possible world number one Magnus Carlsen
with a slight smile there he